jumping into spoilers um
when you were telling dwayne
and the cat ryan gull um did you tell
them about the twist in the third act
like when you're describing the movie or
did you say please read the script and
then let them discover that stuff on
their own
so for dwayne i pitched in the whole
story and then got to the twist at the
end and that's actually the moment when
i was having dinner and i pitched in the
story and he's listening he's eating a
steak and drinking
he's like i'm
kind of into it i'm like all right maybe
and then i get to the twist uh where you
know john hartley is actually the bishop
dwayne is actually working with gao and
he got up and he threw his napkin down
and he said i'm in i'm in a man i'm in
uh and then i got really drunk
[Laughter]
kidding of course but um
but for gal like i said i flew to london
and i pitched her so it was the same
thing and i pitched gal uh
and she was so smart like she's like she
does not miss a trick so she was like
poking holes the whole way and like
calling out twists and turns and i was
like oh no she's gonna get this and then
at the end
i tell her that actually she and dwayne
are on the same side and she didn't see
it coming and she was delighted uh and
said yes so i think i think that worked
and then for ryan uh i just sent him the
script i just sent him the script and
said
uh you know uh i i i hope you like it
and he uh and he read it and signed up
the next day
i wonder also listen if you have dwayne
and gaul uh attached and then you're
sending it to ryan it's like i mean
there's a good chance he's going to be
like this this i'm probably going to you
know
well i think you'd have to ask him but i
think i think when you send somebody a
script that has dwayne johnson and gal
gadot attached they'll read it at the
very least oh that's for damn sure so i
a few years ago and it could be the
story you're talking about with dwayne
there's a photo of you guys having a
meal and he wrote he tweeted
uh this is back in february of 2018. he
posted a pic of you guys and he said my
character will make you think twice
about ever judging a book by its cover
even after you've read every page and he
was basically giving away
the movie
but no one realized at that point he's
giving away the movie yeah yeah yeah
that's the actual dinner and um and uh
yeah that he dwayne's tricky man i mean
he's he's kind of been playing cards up
uh on his uh on his instagram if you go
back and read his post about his
character it's all there yeah it's it's
crazy i was really really um surprised
by that so the ending of the movie yeah
um you end in paris and you mentioned so
what was the original what did you
originally have in terms of what was the
item they were going to steal or you
want to not say because it could change
i'd rather not say if that's okay
totally fine so did you end up picking
paris just because
it is a city that like has so much
history that something can happen there
well sure i mean paris uh is you know
romantic and uh and
and thrilling and the louvre of course
is the you know the greatest museum in
the world uh and and the most iconic so
to me uh you know our three giant movie
stars heading into the most iconic
museum in the world to steal something
dot dot dot is a pretty uh pretty
delicious
uh morsel to dangle
obviously i'm sure netflix after seeing
the test scores
seeing everyone's reaction is like oh we
we could use more of this so um you know
the biggest i think the tricky part of
course is scheduling with these actors
and having a script everyone likes and
all that stuff but um are you
currently working on like a script a
draft an idea is is netflix saying to
you hey
sure uh well i'm not uh
working on the script for a sequel uh i
certainly
uh i've been noodling with with what i
would do
uh for for a follow-up and um yeah and
you know not since telltale's out of
school but but yeah netflix uh uh we've
been having those conversations
oh uh please i'm unloading that this is
a no-brainer um
is there is there pressure though when
you've delivered a big twist like this
in red notice um is there pressure to
like sort of do another m night esque
twist in a sequel or is it sort of like
do you know what i mean like are you
already thinking about that well that
that is such a smart question i've never
made a sequel before um
if i were to make one for red notice
it'd be my first and uh yeah i mean i
think i think when you when you set the
bar at a you know at a certain height uh
the next one you want to try to clear it
um and and i think i think that relates
to to every element of the first film
uh with this film one of the things you
have to do i've watched it twice and one
of the things that is cool is that when
you re-watch it it's all there the whole
everything about the ending is is just
building towards it so i'm curious with
the editing process how tricky was it to
sort of
deliver nuggets while also not giving
away everything that's a another great
question um
so for me
uh obviously we stitch it all the way
through
and my hope in the editing process was
what i wanted to do was break it uh
before we fix it meaning that i put in
everything i put in too much where where
when we were showing it to early
audiences
you know
10 would go like oh it's dwayne right
and then and then as soon as we had that
i was like okay now let's pull it back
let's take these two other beats out and
then it goes down to almost nobody and
that's what you want you want to be
right on that edge so that exactly what
happened with you when you watch it the
second time you're like you know you you
slap your forehead because it it's right
there in front of you um and that's
that's the fun right oh 100 were you
nervous about test screening this with
having the twist sort of get out so
early or during the process you know uh
i never really was i i guess um
maybe i should have been uh but i i
guess to me
i
i just sort of had faith in the
movie-going audience to not want to
spoil something for other people
um and i think there's sort of a
you know a code of honor
about that at least i like to think that
so
just
stay in that little circle of you'd like
to think that
oh man uh yeah i maybe i maybe i should
have been a little more hesitant but i
mean what's what's the alternative not
test the movie we couldn't do that
yeah i mean
of course